l'immunité collective c'est l'objectif
ultime de la stratégie vaccinale la clé
de voûte de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire le temps est à l'immunité
collective mais tant que nous n'aurons
pas atteint cette immunité collective
chacun peut prendre part à l'épreuve
d'immunité collective il faut qu'on
atteigne l'immunité collective plusieurs
ont parlé spontanément de l'immunité
collective jusque là le retour à la vie
normale était conditionnée à cette
immunité collective sauf que les
variants notamment le variant delta
viennent compliquer les choses à
commencer par la part de la population
vaccinée ou guéris à atteindre au début
de l'épidémie on parlait de 65% avec le
variant delta et bien c'est beaucoup
plus il faudrait que 90 % des plus de 12
ans soient vaccinés ou soit protégée
parce qu'ils ont été infectées nous
faisons face à un variant du virus le
fameux variant delta qui est très
contagieux et qui impose une mesure
énergique de vaccination pour arriver à
cette immunité de groupe mais surtout
même en atteignant ces 90% et bien il se
pourrait que l'immunité collective soit
impossible à atteindre
nous sommes ici dans une situation avec
ce variant actuel ou l'immunité
collective n'est pas envisageable car il
affecte toujours les individus vaccinés
le professeur britannique par là même du
mythe de l'immunité collective et c'est
vrai que par exemple une étude publiée
récemment semblent démontrer que les
personnes vaccinées infectées par le
virus ont une charge virale similaire
aux non vaccinés les auteurs suggèrent
que les personnes vaccinées pourraient
donc être des sources de transmission de
la maladie ce qui vient sacrément
affaiblir la stratégie de l'immunité de
groupe par la vaccination massive d'un
autre côté et bien ce n'est jamais si
simple les auteurs de l'étude eux-mêmes
invite à la prudence et à des analyses
complémentaires et puis il ya cette
étude de lyme derrière le collège de
londres paris où il y a une semaine qui
suggère linverse le papier indique
également que les personnes vaccinées
ont deux à trois fois moins de chances
d'être testée positive que les autres il
est donc peut-être encore un peu tôt
pour enterrer définitivement la
stratégie vaccinale de l'immunité
collective même s'il n'ya pas à
qu'outre-manche qu'on s'interroge
l'épidémiologiste en chef islandais a
par exemple déclaré qu obtenir
l'immunité collectif par la vaccination
générale et est hors d'atteinte bref on
nage encore on nous trouble et notamment
les autorités sanitaires à travers le
monde qui ont pris des mesures pour
atteindre au plus vite l'immunité
collective des mesures parfois très
impopulaire comme le pass sanitaires ici
en france